this is a once-in-a-lifetime thing turn
your iPad's over I don't think we're
gonna see traditional textbooks in five
years in really any classroom in the
United States but this is what you might
see an entirely digital k to 12
curriculum for the ipad the first of its
kind created by pearson the world's
largest educational publisher as part of
its aggressive strategy to dominate the
education market by embracing new
technology i think this is a chance to
really engage and motivate kids in ways
that we haven't been able to for a long
time pearson knew about educating kids
but they needed help making the leap to
digital so they turn to possible a
global web and app developer pearson
came to us to say how can we create a
user experience how can we create an
application that's going to be
successful in the classroom is going to
work for the teachers and is going to
work for the students possible had
designed for clients like nike microsoft
and coke but teaching kids math and
english that demanded a new lesson plan
so this is actually after here this move
between a student choosing unit going
into their lesson and being able to
access the rest of content so it started
six eight ten months ago simply as some
mike board markers of mooses entire
process and ends up being workable code
that's been distributed to students as
we that code turned into 28 digital math
and english courses each unit is filled
with real-world illustrations hands-on
exercises built in notebooks for writing
and drawing and supplemental activities
we have Interactive's that a printed
page cannot have we have videos and
animations that are part of each lesson
they're not separate from but there are
part of this spinning house a seventh
grade geometry lesson for students at
Obama prep in Los Angeles so in this
particular lesson they present a house
plan how it relates to what you would do
with architecture to build add on to it
or to figure out what size the floors
you need that kind of stuff is that
different from the way you learn math
last
yes because the camera goes around the
house and we could see how the the
length or width it's a better
educational experience for kids that's
what's behind us also behind it a five
year study to determine if technology
delivers on its promise